Allen we started talking a good deal
in which Jesus almost
instantly raises opposition by his words
and his deeds then we've had a couple
sessions where we're mostly talking
about his relationship to the disciples
they're trying to figure out who is this
man and and maybe he trying to figure
out who he is in terms of his own
ministry but now as we move into chapter
11 and come two-thirds of the way almost
through our gospel opposition begins to
mount again what's going on do you think
a few things I think one is change of
venue because in Chapter 11 we get the
triumphal entry into Jerusalem so Jesus
riding on a donkey in at the loud
acclaim of his followers and others and
he enters the city for the first time
and in fact down the road we're gonna
see the disciples marveling at the size
of the buildings in the temple this is
their first trip to the big city in in
this gospel and so it's a new place with
new Jewish leadership and so the issues
almost immediately start alright one I
mean and it's not by priests or Levite
or a scribe or anyone coming up to him
he begins by walking immediately from
the entry into the temple and throwing
some things around challenging the
temple as reasserting that it's a house
of prayer over against being a den of
robbers that it's been made into so
Jesus throws down the glove we talked
earlier on about shortly after his
parables he starts showing his
sovereignty showing what kingdom looks
like about lepers and outsiders now is
he showing what kingdom looks like
around the temple and the Jerusalem yeah
the the opponents the chief priests are
going to soon after his time the temple
come a task Wow by what authority do you
do the things you do and so it clearly
was in their perception an act of
authority yeah right and so it comes in
he's he comes into his space in a way
and rearranges you know and challenges
and and I think one of the things that's
different between these later chapters
and the conflict that happened in
Chapter 11 and
chapter 12 with the early ones is it
early on we had conflict over who could
forgive sins and we had conflict over
with whom somebody ought to eat and we
had conflict over what you can do or not
do on Sabbath whether fasting is a good
exercise right faithful people all right
those are matters of interpretation of
law yeah here we get Jesus going right
at practice in a more prophetic way so
if he was he was seeming rabbinic in
Galilee
all right now arguing the niceties of
the law from a particular perspective
right now he moves over to looking more
prophetic yeah challenging with a God's
eye view the way faith religion is being
lived out in this place and time and and
so they have they have some skirmishes
not just in the temple after the temple
we get a question about his authority
and then he tells a story in which the
parable of the tenants and they don't
come off very favourably right the
Jewish leaders they do not come off very
favourably in fact the the culmination
is this vineyard owner wants fruit from
his vineyard that's all he wants and so
he sends people to get it and they keep
getting beat up and so finally he sends
his son and says they'll listen to him
and he gets killed and by now we've
heard who the son has to be because
we've had God saying a couple times
here's my son by the way this is my son
yeah yeah so we had the first verse of
the gospel and there got a couple times
and even demons saying my god so we know
narrative ly we know you know as the
audience son has to be yeah and and the
the telling of this parable evokes
opposition so great that they would go
after him except the crowds are too big
in his favor so we see the crowds come
in here again to this time as kind of a
shield to Jesus they went along yeah
which in a way goes back to my nears
point that they're the undecided but
sometimes useful hangers-on yeah not
quite there yet but not against him
either right he can he can hide behind
him a little bit
figuratively because he doesn't it he
doesn't seem to draw back right by they
are the fact that they're there and the
other the other crowd in sight here and
and part of this is just narrative fun
but I think there may be more to it than
just that is when they ask by what
authority do you do these things jesus
answered well I've got a question for
you the baptism of John was it from God
or from people and they step aside to
deliberate the Jewish leaders do and
they say well if we say from from God
they'll say why didn't you believe him
and if we say from people then they'll
get a the crowds will just get angry
because they thought he was a prophet so
so these people are really these Jewish
leaders are really sensitive to the
power of the mob absolutely well and
then I want to move beyond this very
quickly but one thing we just have not
had time to talk about it won't have
much time to talk about is in how many
of the disputes Jesus who starts out as
the question he becomes the questioner
that his way of answering is to turn the
question back on the question Harrison I
remember the place and job where a jobs
been questioning God for 38 chapters and
God finally appears on the scene and
says I'll question you and you answer me
I think that's Jesus claiming his
authority once again thank you very much
scribes and Pharisees now I'll question
you when you answer me and I'm actually
in charge here though you think you're
putting me to the test I get to set the
test yeah and you know that I think that
fits exactly because there are a series
where they ask him questions can we pay
taxes yes Caesar and do we get married
in the resurrection it just kind of lays
it back out of time every time at the
end the last setting in that scene or
that last scene in that series is Jesus
saying whose son is David Yeah right and
and getting at the Messiah question but
it's his question absolutely he he
doesn't they don't even get one off that
time I don't he's in charge well in
charge now he's in Jerusalem he's
already taken charge of the temple once
he comes back to the temple again and
gives his second big long speech we said
two or three times ago they're too big
long speeches chapter 4 chapter 13
chapter 13 takes place where the temples
going on I've written about mark from
time to time I've teach taught mark from
time
I always try to avoid chapter 13 but
here it is tell us about what's going on
and help us think about what to do a
chapter 13 Jesus enters this mysterious
world of apocalypse and we know it from
movie titles and we know it from
sometimes it's use as as an adjective
apocalyptic means something that's
that's very critical is or brings things
to a head in this chapter Jesus starts
to picture for them and with them a
future that God has in hand and it
doesn't look pretty the whole time it
looks challenging to them it looks at
points they're gonna be told you're
gonna be persecuted and your life is
going to get really hard and God will
help you amidst that but it's a it's a
completely new voice and a completely
new almost feel in the in this gospel
it's not that we haven't had urgent e
and the the picture of the spectacular
and and some idea that there would be a
culmination we've had passion
predictions and Jesus's announcement of
his death and all those things but this
is a different bird this is a different
voice in it Jesus seems to be out to
answer two main questions one is when is
this all going to have yeah which
they're very keen on in the narrative
and and Mark's community must have been
very keen on because they're 40 years
out yeah
from pause on that for just a minute
because I do and I have all the way been
assuming what we would be helpful to
reiterate which is our guess is that
Mark's Gospel gets written probably 40
years after the events it narrates right
so this is not yesterday's news it's
good news but it's been refracted and
reflected through the life of the
community for 40 years before it ever
gets written down right and so if Mark
writes about Jesus saying this
generation will not pass away until all
these amazing things and cataclysms
happen that's a little bit of a
challenge to this team that's 40 years
out and we'll come back to that in a
second and I want to ask you about that
but the second thing he's going to
answer is what's going to happen
yeah right for
when because they have some sense Jesus
starts the conversation by saying you'll
they're sitting on the Mount of Olives
he looks over and says you guys these
are impressive buildings sure but
there's not going to be one stone upon
another right right so that all this is
coming down yeah and then and then he
goes to when's it going to happen and
more about what in which a lot of the
message is that faithful people here
keep holding on right right right stay
awake a lot of a lot of well has a kind
of practical daily impact right whatever
you do with all the speculative stuff
which we'll come back to in a way you
know what it looks like day by day you
hang in there you keep your eyes open
you don't give up and if anybody attacks
you be confident that God's could help
you if anybody persecute you if you end
up on the wrong side of public opinion
whatever it is God will give you the
words and and one thing about that I
mean it's it's I think easy for us as
distant readers to slip into seeing
these disciples as what they had become
later right absolutely
but these are these are not people who
have majored in public speaking right
these are not people who have I mean and
we all know all the surveys show that
that public speaking is is more dreadful
than death to a lot of people in our
area everywhere in our culture here oh
so so the idea of facing rulers and
Kings and synagogue leaders and speaking
at all it must have been menacing though
Jesus says to them you know you'll get
the words God will God will take care of
you so he not only envisions the problem
you know he tries to tell them what
would holding on look like what would
what would a proper faithful person do
is setting you know in the in the realm
of trying to get on the table context
which I'm glad you spoke out the 40-year
gap yeah and how we're assuming that the
other thing to bring onto the table is
this this genre of Apocalypse what what
it is what what does it mean when
somebody writes one of these this one's
called a little apocalypse and and there
are a couple of bigger ones
Daniel in the Old Testament and
revelation it's the biggest of which
just which the Greek word is apocalypse
apocalypse yeah that here's the
apocalypse yep
and and so so mark is working with a
tradition of a way of writing yeah that
happens in certain places under certain
conditions that might help us to
understand mark 13 a little better
oppressed people use this as a way of
speaking to our at some times in Daniels
case it comes out of extreme
persecutions under Antiochus Epiphanes
in the 2nd century BC when Jews for
being Jews and faith are being
personality and so they can no longer
say well I was faithless and that's why
I got this the bad end of never admits
murder right now I now all of a sudden I
am I'm doing the right thing and bad
things are happening to me how do i
process that apocalypse comes as an
answer to that for people who are up
against powers greater than themselves
and living out something that those
powers are trying to put down and so it
would be I imagine a welcome message to
these mark and followers who are in a
room somewhere so how does it how does
it speak to us now as 21st century most
of us not persecuted Christians much
used in many churches as a sign of great
hope that God's gonna do something
drastic very soon now we're we're nine
nine and a half a little more than nine
years out from y2k yeah figures out and
and there were people sitting on the
roofs waiting for the time and and that
happens in every generation the the
message I think that's available to us
in this apocalypse in mark is that God
has designs for the world not just for
me who are you
but God has designs for creation and for
all people that aren't yet met okay no
God has a place where this is going and
it it we can anticipate that and live
into it here or toward it and that's a
that's a bright light to shine on this
fact or this truth
trying to communicate it oh that's good
and the other the other piece of that I
think is in an interesting way Jesus
includes his own criticism of the
apocalyptic thought because he says
actually dear friends this is really
important but nobody knows the details
in fact I myself don't know the details
only God the Father knows this so act
faithfully live faithfully trust God
entirely but don't spend your time
working out Church and playing with
calendars on this thing right it reminds
me of the parables when Jesus said you
don't have to worry about who's in and
who's out right right there are places
in this Gospel where Jesus relieves us
of temptations to judge or to to be
obsessed with things and in this place
we don't have to mind the calendar okay
right I think I do too well let's see
how he lives out his own hope for what
God's going to do in the next chapters
yeah that's great